- [Voiceover] We're told
the first four terms
of an arithmetic sequence are given.
So it goes from negative
eight to negative 14
to negative 20 to negative 26.
What is the fifth term in the sequence?
So we just need to
figure out the next term.
Well, in arithmetic sequence,
each successive term is
separated by the same amount.
So when we go from negative
eight to negative 14,
we went down by six and
then we go down by six again
to go to negative 20 and
to go to negative 26, and
so we're gonna go down
by six again to get to negative 32.
Negative 32.
Let's do a couple more of these.
The first five terms of
the sequence are given.
What is the sixth term?
Let's see, to go from two to negative one,
you subtracted three.
Two minus three is negative one.
Negative one minus three is negative four.
Negative four minus
three is negative seven.
Negative seven minus three is negative 10.
And so negative 10 minus
three is negative 13.
So hopefully that gives
you the hang of things.